We've seen the "Cinderella" story told a
dozen different ways, but we've never seen
everyone's favorite underdog princess
like this. This Ella is a princess
made for 2021, and her movie has some
details that only adults will notice.
Kids who aren't well-versed in music history
might think most of the music in "Cinderella"
is original. However, the movie is actually
littered with many delightful takes on '70s,
'80s, and '90s music. The first song Cinderella
sings isn't original to the movie at all, in fact:
It's a take on the 1994 song "You
Gotta Be" by R&B artist Des'ree.
Younger audiences might recognize certain other
classic songs, like Prince Robert's version of
Queen's "Somebody to Love," or Vivian's
rendition of Madonna's "Material Girl."
Less omnipresently popular songs will
probably elude them, however -- but not
the adults in the audience, who
will be jamming until the end.
The movie features appearances from
Salt-N-Pepa's "Whatta Man," Earth,
Wind & Fire's "Shining Star," as
well as Jennifer Lopez's 1999 hit,
"Let's Get Loud," which provides the
last, show-stopping musical number.
Original songs like "Million to One" round out the
soundtrack, along with more recent additions to
the world's pop songbook. Prince Robert and Ella's
charming slow dance to Ed Sheeran's "Perfect" is
especially memorable. But otherwise, this movie
is a master class in recent music history.
If kids haven't heard these jams before watching,
they'll certainly be blasting them on repeat now.
"Cinderella" has a number of fairly unsubtle
innuendoes (we're looking at you, mice), but
Princess Laura's is especially attention-grabbing.
We'd expect nothing less from the posh-yet-savage
princess: We only get to know her for a few
minutes, but she completely steals the show.
In her dismal meeting with Prince
Robert, during which she condescendingly
explains to him what a map is, she tries
to arrange a mutually beneficial marriage.
She leaves frustrated when Robert shows no
interest in her proposal, even though she's
perfectly chill with him hanging out with his
bros and never spending time together -- except
for when they have to engage in what she
calls the disgusting practice of having a son.
When she leaves the meeting in a
huff, she gets the last laugh when
she addresses the other princess
hopefuls on her way out the door.
It'll fly over children's heads, but Laura's dig
criticizes his desirability from top to bottom,
from his brain down to his — well, you know.
Forget about marriage — Laura's parting dig
calls into question whether or not this dense
prince would be worth a romp in the hay at all.
Here's a sentiment every
woman is tired of hearing:
"You'd be prettier if you did x, y, or z!"
Countless women throughout history have
dealt with this condescending "compliment."
While young girls certainly face
their fair share of criticism,
this particular bit of nastiness is
most often applied to adult women.
Women who tear other women down out of
internalized misogyny also use this line,
something "Cinderella" vividly captures:
Ella's stepmother Vivian constantly
does this to her stepdaughter.
Never mind that Vivian forces her stepdaughter to
live in a dingy basement with
only a few mice for friends.
The misogynistic undertones of most
fairy tale-based movies are prominent,
and it's refreshing to see a modern take turn
these tropes on their head. This creates a more
positive message and gives young women the
tools they need to call out this behavior.
Unlike most iterations of "Cinderella," this
story's Ella doesn't need to change herself to
win Prince Robert's favor: She catches his eye
in a ragged dress and messy hair. Even when Ella
prepares for the ball, she doesn't get made over
into a glamorous stranger. She looks the same,
in fact, except she's wearing the dress
she designed. It's an empowering choice.
Not everyone can be as subtle
about innuendo as Princess Laura,
but Ella's three best friends (yes, they're
mice) try their hardest. When Fab G turns
Ella's mice besties into three human footmen,
Ella is confused to discover they're male.
Well, that's not how that works, Ella.
James Corden's mouse-human asks
the question on everyone's mind:
"How do you think rats have more rats?"
Fab G is quick to steer the conversation
away from breaking the news to Ella that
mouse babies don't get delivered by storks.
Things get even more uncomfortable after
the mice drop off Ella at the palace.
There, James Corden's mouse-human
makes it weird again by announcing
that he's relieved himself
from his, um, front tail.
Most kids watching "Cinderella" likely
recognize Idina Menzel and Camila Cabello:
Menzel voices Elsa of "Frozen" fame,
and Cabello is a famous pop star.
But kids tuning into this might not realize
that Billy Porter is Broadway royalty.
Porter hit the scene in the early '90s when he
played Teen Angel in the 1994 "Grease" revival.
More roles soon followed, culminating
in the one that made Porter a household
name in the world of theater: Lola in 2013's
"Kinky Boots." Porter originated this role,
and garnered multiple awards, including the Tony
for Best Actor in a Musical, in the process.
While certain teens might recognize Porter from
"American Horror Story" or "Pose," even they might
be ignorant of his luminous Broadway history.
After watching "Cinderella," however, they might
be inspired to check it out, as Porter is the
perfect person to take on the role of Fab G.
He always brings a unique pizazz to any part he
takes on -- especially ones as glamorous as this.
Most kids would rather enjoy the movie
than focus on its glaring plot holes.
As it turns out, Fab G agrees with that sentiment.
That said, adults can't help picking
apart plotlines that don't make sense,
even when magic is involved. For example,
Fab makes it abundantly clear that when the
clock strikes midnight, the magic will wear
off. But despite the fact that magic does
eventually flicker out of every single thing Fab G
bewitched, the glass slippers remain intact. Huh?
We watch as Ella's dress flutters away into
the wind, the human mice turn back into their
four-legged selves, and the carriage transforms
into a hunk of junk. Yet days after the ball, Ella
still has a fully intact glass slipper hiding in
her basket, while Prince Robert has the other one.
That's not the only odd thing adults will notice,
either. Is Ella's shoe size really that special
that no one else matches it? Moreover, the
prince has seen Ella both dolled up and
in tattered clothes. If the shoe fits an entirely
different woman, is he really ready to abandon
everything he knows about Ella and run off with
a rando? Is he completely face-blind? He doesn't
even find her with the shoe, so this fairly
nonsensical plotline isn't even necessary.
Throughout "Cinderella," the king seems
to be overcompensating for something.
His frequent power trips aren't exactly out
of character for a king, but his particular
preoccupations imply he might be insecure about
something only adults will take notice of.
King Rowan constantly talks about
the size of everything around him.
Characters bring up the fact that he's had his
minions make his throne slightly larger not once,
but twice. This bit of innuendo gets
a laugh out of the older audience,
to be sure. But it also develops into a
lesson everyone can learn from. We all
have things we're insecure about, regardless of
our social status, fame, or fortune. But how we
treat the people around us is more important
than whatever trivial detail we agonize over.
Despite the king's self-consciousness, he
learns to stop putting down his loved ones
and to respect and honor each of their strengths,
regardless of the norms of the
time. Talk about character growth.
Whirlwind romances are the norm in princess
films, but in reality, it takes time to get
to know someone. Of course, in the eras that
inspired the setting of "Cinderella," modern
dating didn't exist. But an adult still can't help
but flinch at Ella and Prince Robert's choices.
Proposing marriage after one date is absurd,
and the prince is selfish to ask
her to give up her dreams. However,
the tables eventually turn when Prince Robert
gives up his dreams for Ella's sake. But while
Robert may say that he's not very interested
in royal life or becoming king, he's making
a very rash decision at a young age that will
affect his life and the future of the kingdom.
Robert does, at one point, even tell his
father that there's nothing he wants more
than to be king. He needs to give
himself a chance to mature into
wanting that role before running off
with Ella, lest he come to resent her.
There's no denying that Gwen is a better fit for
the throne, and Ella and Robert don't get married
immediately. But this is still a case of someone
-- a very young someone -- giving up everything
for another person. It's the prince instead of the
princess this time, but it still demonstrates a
lack of foresight the grown-ups in the audience
will recognize as potentially destructive.